[Musica]
voi siete dei sognatori
io lo sono anzi lo sono sempre stata fin
da quando ero bambina
sognavo di ballare sul palcoscenico e
ricevere tanti applausi
ero serena perché a casa quando uscivano
tutti io spostavo le sedi del salotto e
iniziavo a provare i miei passi le
mettevo tutto infine loro diventavano il
mio pubblico mi applaudivano sempre
le mie gambe
la mia assicurazione sul futuro volevo
vivere di danza e diventare una
ballerina professionista
volevo investire sulle mie gambe ma
proprio le mie gambe sono state le prime
ad abbandonarmi se si sono rese ad un
nemico invisibile
proprio la parte del corpo sulla quale
avrei scommesso è stata la prima ad
abbandonarmi a
11 anni ho iniziato a zoppicare
inciampavo delle mie gambe cadevo per
terra
non so perché ma stavo male
la mia gamba sinistra era rigida rigida
come un pezzo di legno
sempre
ho iniziato a girovagare con i miei
genitori da decine di medici facendo
ricoveri lunghissimi ed esami
dolorosissimi ad ogni medico dicevo
sempre gli stessi sintomi
visione offuscata visione doppia
stanchezza rigidità muscolare
tremoli formicolii scosse alla schiena
scosse alle gambe io continuavo a
raccontare i miei sintomi e loro di
contro continuavano a dirmi che la solo
espresso
la parola stress mi ha perseguitata per
quasi vent'anni
fino a quando all'età di 29 anni
finalmente la diagnosi è arrivata e non
era espressa il mio nemico aveva un nome
e un cognome sclerosi multipla
alla faccia dello stress
quando è arrivata la diagnosi
io mi sono sentita sollevata
non ci crederete ma l'ho considerata
addirittura una bella notizia
e sì perché quando insegui per 20 anni
una diagnosi tutto ti sembra difficile
quando racconti tuoi sintomi ma ti
sembra che nessuno ti crede
vorresti scomparire io da quel momento
potevo ricominciare la mia vita la luce
del sole
potevo ricominciare a camminare in mezzo
alla gente senza più paura senza più
nascondermi e soprattutto potevo dire i
miei sintomi e non vergognarmi di dire
ciò che stavo provando
potevo guardare in faccia il mio nemico
e combatterlo ad armi pari eh sì
beh dopo la diagnosi
io ho ricominciato a sognare sì mi
sentivo serena ho ricominciato a sognare
soprattutto quel palcoscenico magico
volevo continuare a fare quel mestiere
purtroppo la danza non poteva più far
parte della mia vita perché le mie gambe
non ce la facevano più ma mi sono
impegnata e ho studiato l'eccitazione
per diventare un'attrice ho smesso le
scarpe da ballerina per indossare quelle
dell'attrice
ho fatto un cambio di genere di scarpe
d'altronde molti attori dicono che un
personaggio nasce a partire dalle scarpe
tutti immagini cosa mai indossasse
giulietta ai piedi e voilà diventi
giulietta ecco anche io in qualche modo
sono rinata dalle scarpe la recitazione
è diventata il motore della mia gioia
la mia ancora di salvezza
e stato bellissimo
ricominciare a recitare va non è stato
facile essere accettata l'attrice
disabile in italia suona ancora male per
tutti l'attrice è quella tutta curve e
sguardo invitante
l'attrice con il tacco 12
sì
quella con la stampella 112
e pensare che nella patria dei lustrini
e delle paillettes io rappresento
l'emancipazione l'innovazione del
piccolo schermo
eppure per molti colleghi l'attrice
disabile non andava bene non riuscivano
a capire come mai io fossi un attrice e
avessi anche un problema di salute
mi ricordo che una volta è ospite in un
talk show
accanto a me un uomo dotato di grande
cultura
un uomo approdato alla televisione per
la sua testa
per la sua intelligenza
un tronista
ecco quest'uomo mi guarda e nella pausa
pubblicitaria mi fa c'è scusa ma fammi
capire cioè ma quindi tu cioè se
un'attrice cioè e sei anche malata
sì cioè
e invece vedo che la parte del pirla
viene proprio benissimo è c'è
non ti devi neanche impegnare si va beh
non gli ho detto proprio così però avrei
voluto veramente dirglielo perché è
assurdo che male c'è a portare avanti il
connubio arte e malattia e poi tu puoi
essere un se le professioniste avere un
problema di salute non è che per sapere
a citare devi per forza saper correre
ma anche le mie colleghe non digerivano
all'attrice disabile anzi mi vivevano
come una minaccia
quando sono approdata la televisione
tanti articoli sono usciti dedicati a me
tante copertine dei giornali e loro
questa cosa non la mandavano giu perché
quella copertina lei e non me sono più
bella più mani
io spiega volo che tutte quelle
copertine erano di delicate all'attrice
disabile non all'attrice tutti quegli
articoli sui giornali erano per la
sclerosi multipla non per il mio talento
io ne avrei veramente fatto a meno e mi
sarei portato a casa una salute perfetta
ho cercato di farglielo capire ma loro
continuavano a vivermi come una minaccia
tant'è che un giorno una mia collega
collega attrice mi ha detto scusa ma
fammi capire volerete tutti i ruoli dei
disabili devono da reati sono capace
anch'io eh
e poi scusa
dimmi tu che sei dell'ambiente ma quelli
come te fanno parte di maggio infine
apposta
quindi lei pensa pensa che come esistono
le paraolimpiadi esistono anche le par
agenzie per il par attori una cosa
assurda assurda io lo so ci sto
scherzando sopra ma tutti combattiamo la
nostra battaglia probabilmente anche
loro combattono la loro però insomma
ragazzi
io ho studiato per fare l'attrice e sono
diventato l'attrice ho realizzato il mio
sogno
dopo la diagnosi non ho ricominciato a
sognare solo nell'ambito lavorativo
ho ricominciato a sognare anche nella
vita privata mi sentivo pronta per una
storia importante per l'amore con la a
maiuscola
e l'amore con la a maiuscola è arrivato
è arrivato con un po di ritardo ma è
arrivato robbie è il mio tutto l'altra
parte della mela con lui ho subito
pensato di invecchiare serena di
costruire una famiglia
volevamo dei figli 12 potevano bastare
ci abbiamo provato ma sembrava che un
figlio non volesse arrivare
l'orologio biologico correva
all'impazzata
io non avevo più tanto tempo così ce
l'abbiamo messa tutta ma un figlio non è
arrivato
abbiamo subito pensato all'adozione
che bello dare amore un bambino più
sfortunato un altro sogno da realizzare
peccato che quel sogno molto presto si è
trasformato in un incubo
a noi un figlio non l'avrebbero mai dato
perché io ho una patologia
neurodegenerativa
io non sono idonei a diventare mamma
perché cammino con una stampella e
magari un giorno avrò bisogno di una
sedia a rotelle che poi non è detto
aveva una patologia neurodegenerativa
non significa degenerare per forza che
poi anche se fosse
anche se io finissi su una sedia rotelle
quante mamme in sedia a rotelle conosco
che sono serene e crescono con amore i
propri figli
e quanti figli di donne in sedia a
rotelle crescono sereni per nulla
traumatizzati e risolti e allora perché
io dovrei traumatizzare un bambino un
bambino ha bisogno di una madre
amorevole non di una madre perfetta un
bambino ha bisogno di genitori che lo
crescano con amore con attenzione non
dei genitori che sappiano fare cento
metri
questa è una battaglia che io voglio
portare avanti è come se lo farò
probabilmente aveva un figlio non lo
daranno più in adozione perché sono
troppo vecchia ma io voglio lottare per
tutte le donne che desiderano diventare
mamme spero che almeno il loro sogno si
realizzi
e comunque come potete immaginare la mia
vita è stata spesso in bianco e nero io
ho sempre cercato però di colorarla di
colorarla con tutta me stessa di
renderla positiva anche la mia stampella
il mio ausilio ortopedico
io l'ho trasformato molto presto in un
accessorio glamour fashion tutto
colorato guardate la mia stampella non è
grigia blu nera è piena di colori piena
di vita come me
i bambini
le chiamano le stampelle di barbie un
bambino un giorno mia sopra minato lella
la fatina della stampella
io mi sono innamorata di questa
definizione e ho deciso di creare un
fumetto di lella la fatina della
stampella e vorrei tanto imprimerlo su
delle stampelle pediatriche o
addirittura a pubblicarlo in un libro
nella la fatina della stampella è una
fatina che ha una stampella magica che
trasforma la tristezza in allegria la
paura in forza la vergogna in
opportunità
io ho un altro grande sogno quello di
dar vita a una linea di stampelle
dedicate ai bambini e gli adulti e la
vita mi ha insegnato che molto spesso i
sogni si realizzano soprattutto se tu mi
vuoi con tutta te stessa io ho
realizzato molti miei sogni ho
realizzato il sogno del principe azzurro
e il principe azzurro nella mia vita è
arrivato
ho realizzato il sogno di diventare
un'attrice ho realizzato il sogno di
lavorare con un grande del cinema come
pupi avati e soprattutto ho realizzato
un sogno che pensavo irrealizzabile
calcare il palcoscenico del festival di
sanremo
ebbene sì io fin da piccola sognavo quel
palco volevo fare la valletta aveva un
ruolo ma essere al teatro ariston di
sanremo e il sogno un anno fa si è
realizzato
amadeus mi ha telefonato e mi ha
proposto di recitare un pezzo del mio
spettacolo proprio su quel magico palco
è stata un'emozione grandissima
io mi sono ritrovata a marzo 2021
davanti a 11 milioni di telespettatori
a raccontare la mia vita a recitare un
pezzo del mio spettacolo
le gambe mi tremavano come non mai
davanti a me non c'era il pubblico
perché in platea non poteva esserci per
il covip
ma io ho sentito tutto il calore del
pubblico a casa che mi avvolgeva con
amore
avevo un vestito bellissimo rosso grande
sembrava una principessa avevo dei
tacchi vertiginosi e faticavo a starci
sopra anche la mia stampella sembrava
alta in modo vertiginoso
io quella sera ho realizzato il sogno di
raccontare ne stessa di recitare un
pezzo del mio spettacolo ma soprattutto
di gridare al mondo quello che stasera
voglio dire anche a voi io non sono la
mia malattia io sono antonella e sono la
protagonista della mia vita
lei la sclerosi multipla farà parte di
me per sempre ma avrà solo un ruolo
marginale da comparsa da comprimaria non
di più l'oggetto della mia vita rimane
saldo delle mie mani perché ricordate lo
gli unici protagonisti della nostra vita
siamo noi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì